And that brings us to the end of this course today.
Hopefully you learned a lot of information about V-Cams and how to set them up.
It was a little bit heavy with the technical setup at the start.
It's a very kind of step-by-step methodical processor.
Hopefully once you've got it set up, you're kind of familiar with what everything does
and then the settings don't change too much so you can just next time jump straight into
using virtual camera.
Without your scenes, use the different app functionalities to really help navigate and
scout the locations that you want to use.
And then when you actually start beginning the recording using take recorder or any other
powerful features of Unreal Engine, it allows you to really quickly record and iterate and
dial in those performances and then get them rendered out in sequencer.
So hopefully you learned a lot today and we'll see you on the next course.